*woof*
Oh, my go-
noooOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOoooo
Gooooood
Morning gamers! Welcome back to another beautiful day in Minecraft
I had a live stream yesterday and someone told me to plant 4 spruce trees next to each other and BAM!
Woah, woah
Woahh. Why do I feel like it's challenging Ikea Tower?
Don't worry, IKEA tower. You are beautiful forever. If you didn't catch the live stream, don't worry. You didn't miss much
I just walked around and it was very peaceful and very nice.
I can crick with the Trident?
:o    JE-
Oh my god Bengt. Can you get out of the boat? You're not supposed to-
*squeak*
AAA! Sorry
How do I get him out? Oh my god, they're stuck forever
Leashes gets them out. I keep forgetting. Oh he,- awwwwww thats so cute!
So someone told me they go to sleep underneath trees. That is so cute
ˢˡᵉᵉᵖ ˡᶦᵗᵗˡᵉ ᶜʰᶦˡᵈ
Oh my god, I'll put a little lantern.
Oh, okay. Sorry, sleep. SLEEEP! (yeah because yelling at him will surely make him sleep)
JUST GO TO SLEEP!
Thank you,  tehehe. I don't know if this is true or not
But apparently you can give them a sword as well cuz they keep stuff in their mouth just like Dark Souls
Oh my god. Okay. Thanks
Come on you can be just like Dark Souls
Eat it. I can give him my badass sword and it will give him like fire aspect and stuff
this sword is very important to me, but I want you to have it because you are important to me too.
I need him to drop the leash somehow.
maybe if I give him porkchop
There we go. He just spits it out. *weird sound*
He's eating it. Oh my god. Yes, that's so cool
So apparently he gets the enchantment we need to try this out this is so cool. Alright who wants to volunteer?
All of you, that's very well, I'm just gonna leave a look at him look at him
Look at him bengt is going crazy!
Oh my god, alright. Alright, I'll just leave these guys here. You can do whatever you want them kill them
Kill them now. Well, the backwards attack. Look it's cooked chicken because my sword
That's so awesome. Well, I guess you two are the lucky ones oh
My god, he killed them as well
Very- very interesting technique that Bengt has using his
Why is the chicken just not running away
Incredible technique! aww they're friends..
Oh and now he went to sleep with little chicken in his mouth
*cute giggle*
Now obviously I'm still homeless
I've been trying to figure out what I want to build and we'll probably build something or at least start it today. I'm really excited for
What our new house is gonna be but this time I want to go big
I'm always such a Swedish loser. And I always like oh, I just want to build a small little home for me and my pigs
No, not today
Today we go big we go all out. But first, of course, I have to terrorize my villagers. Yes.
I have this new system set up which I think you guys are gonna really like. Sven has been guarding them to make sure
Good job, Sven.
So I have a I have a very well-hidden - what is it? - observer here
Which if you can see there's a line of thread here. So if anyone passes this thread observer will notice and the trap will activate
Now so far not a single soul has managed to escape this prison right Sven
Yes
But just for a safety meas- no, the boat is not for you Sven
You want to be the guard boat?
Fine. Okay fine
All right, let's remove this and let's watch them walk into the trap. You're free! Oh no!
Bahahahaahahah
Anyone else want to be free?
Why is that so funny?
You guys are free. You can run. Look you can play both with Sven
You know what to be honest, I think I only need one right now
Let's actually feed them a bit more I need more babies
Keep eating and keep fricken. Oh
It's working. Excellent. I have to cover up the whole thing because babies can still crawl in through tiny holes
Which is kind of an oceans and I haven't made this with babies and oh
Well, how do you do?
Okay, this is perfect so this is my new transportation system, oh yeah, I showed her already
Well, the reason you featured to it, you see the track doesn't go up now. I
Put the track over here and then it will go up up into there. Was that which so oh
My God where huh in my spawner so I improved my spawner based on one of you 9 rolls. Oh
It works. I'm supposed to me. I made it one by one, but it's better if you make it 2 by 2
So now you can see my training is a little broken. I get the XP bang bang BAM, it's full and
The loot gets dropped in here
Excellent. Well
What you nine year olds told me are one of you is that you may think this is a fun roller coaster ride
Well, I guess in a way it is they get their final
final ride before the
Before the eternal suffering Oh God. Oh, they're all in here, huh?
So I will they will be placed here
Forever and that will make more mobs spawn if there's a villager and they will move more towards the center as well
I think I know one of those things is true at least
So it's time for our annual lottery. That's right Sven
One of these lucky contestant will be randomly picked
They look like one giant guy hey, hey, sorry sorry, sir one lucky contestant
Will get chosen as tribute. I think this will go pretty fast, but I'll try and follow three
Actually, I kind of want to see them getting pigs. Okay. So when are you ready? Here we go. Three, two one three
Two one
Here we go. And
There he goes lucky wither let's follow him Sven
See, I'm so nice to my villagers. They get a lucky chance to live a new life
There he is perfectly placed excellent
Why
I'm actually gonna keeping them in the minecart for now because I think I'm supposed to get two or three of them
You know, it's it's not really fair. Like I haven't even written this I
Just let other people have fun
It's really not about me. All right, one more lucky win there. Here we go. Three two one people and
We have a winner. Congratulations sir. Sorry, I haven't really outfit y'all get you a job eventually
So, how's married life Sven? H-how is it? I'm about to get married myself, you know
Cool that's good to know. Hey, hey get off my property. Oh, sorry
It was me
Damn Sven's boyfriend Loki Savage
all there's Swen's son
So cute. So you guys said that I should make
Sven's son
Purple because red plus blue
Is purple but I wanted Sven's boyfriend to be yellow. So that makes green. So he's green just so we're clear
This is matter to anyone No. Oh, right. I forgot what I was doing completely. I forgot about them people up here
There should be two of them up here. Oh, no, did he push the other one down?
Why am I laughing
That's awful so now zombies will spawn on these squares they'll they'll be like, oh I want him
I want his sexy body. He looks so nice
Oh
God, I'm about to fall in the hole. But I also still want him
Oh god, that hole is really coming closer, but I love him
He's so sexy. But oh my god. I'm about to fall into giant pit
Maybe there's more of them down there. Okay. See you later
That's how I envisioned it. Have fun now
Cool so, hopefully it works better now as you can see I put IKEA bird on my shoulder
as honor of Ikea bird
Thank you for your service. IKEA bird never forgetting my spaghetti
Man Bank looks so cute next to Dinnerbone's
What who left the door open? Bank who left the door open!?
Where is Dinnerbone? Oh my god. Alright watch this tonight, by the way
Right in his face
So I had this thing for a while in the background a lot of people seemed curious about it. I literally Oh God
oh, no, I wanted to try out because you can make like
Elevators with kelp and Minecraft. I actually want to try that for a very specific reason
Okay, so if I remember correctly you do this. Yeah
BA so we have this water flowing in our beautiful goddamn. That's annoying
But if we put one ah
No, that's not what I wanted to do. Wait
How will is too strong? I mean my shovel. Ah, that's not what I wanted to do either
Okay, you place old son here. And then you're like, oh it does it creates bubbles
Not all the way though. Oh
My god, what is happening flip flop flip flop flip flop flip flop flip it flip flip flip flip flip all the way up
Baby, sween zooming seen soon then you take the soul sand
Did I do it? Is that how you do it No, ah
ah
Oh, it's working I did it I did it
How do I get down from here
Yelp do I have a bucket of water? Yes, I do. Okay, watch this gamers
This is an old veteran minecraft trick you jump and then you drop the water right before you fall
*Awesome Felix*
Good thing I don't have legs cuz otherwise I would have a hurt. Let's try that again. I never actually managed to do it
Here we go
Yeah, you see that. That's so cool
Oh
Smooth
He-he, haha
The idea behind this is to have a sniper tower
Because oh you see that creeper over there watch this
OOOOOH haha haha
He despawn are you kidding me? Alright watch this first try
Got'em moving target no problem
And another one bites the dust
But I wished Sven could see me
Got him look at Bengt don't worry Bank. I got you. Oh
I hit the pig. Sorry
See I swear there's a witch spawn like oh that's far. Oh
My god, I am the lord of Triton, okay, it's time gamers
time to build our new house
Are you excited? You should be right banked. I got a lot of spruce wood and I got a lot of stone
and a lot gotten a lot of patience this time when I build like I said
I'm gonna go figure
All right, not a bad start right banked oh
Yeah, I'm building another Japanese temple, whatever
They just look so awesome. It's kind of cozy underneath as well. Meanwhile, there's one thing I desperately
Forgot to do last time
Which was building a freaking snowman, let's do it right in front of Bank. I think he'll like this
I don't know if this oh my god, that's it. Ha ha ha
What?
Why does it look like that? Oh
Oh, that's creepy
Sven is scared.. Sven, don't worry, it's safe!
What are you? Hello?
That is so creepy
Why does it - is this a joke? Like am I getting - is this the texture pack
Why do they look like that?
Are they evil? Are they evil, Sven? Oh my god, they're leaving trail of snow
Wha? He's peepee pooping himself. He's the actual Peepee poo-poo. Ay ay ay, not too close.
So yeah, my plan with the building is obviously finishing the temple
I might have to move I might have to move Council of water sheep, which is obviously very controversial.
Oh It looks like they have a - Water Sheep is riding the pig
It has been done my lord
Yeah, I might have to move a little bit it's fine
Oh no, he's dying
NOOOOOOOOOOOOO
AAAHHHH
DAMN YOU WATER SHEEP!
Oh my god!
so I don't know if this true or not but I heard that you can - oh my god there's thunder
okay
Okay
I'm going back.
Oh Bengt is scared! Oh no..
He's scared of thunder. Don't worry, you're safe in here
Don't worry, don't worry about it, you're safe in here
So, does my channeling work or does it have to hit something to do it
OHH, It still works, baby
Oh
So what happens if you do it on different things like: sheep. They die. Okay cool. That's good to know
Is there anything else that,
I can use it on
Like a spider
No
Zombie
It's so badass, I love it so much
Creeper, aww mann whoa
What is happening why is he blue?
What what's a blue creeper
Woahhh, it's so cool
Look at you, huh? Oh, uh oh
They make bigger exp- woah, he dropped the head
what??
wait, so if a creeper blows up other mobs then they drop an item?? (question mark)??
Blow up blow up! Creeper, oh, man
What? They drop heads!
Stop hitting me! stop!
I'll take their heads. I thin-  I don't know. AAAAHHH so many of them
Back off children
Pff, BAHAAAAH
Oh no, you're deady deady
I'm too strong
Swedish Zeus
Did it drop? yes, ha ha. Oh man. Ooh, I want an Enderman head.
Ooh, Let me go to sniper tower. Can I wear their heads? Oh my god I can
Sven, booo. Oh my god Sven is gonna freak out
Hey Sv- ow. Hey Sven booo
Ula Britta, it's me. Shh, there's Sven, don't tell Sven.
Hey Sven!
boo
YEAHHH
Okay, Sniper tower, let's go. All right, it's sniping time. All right, you see that zombie?
HO HOOO HA HAAAH
So this is what it's like to be a God among some mortals?
pff-PFFF pf pf pf pf pf pf
Why is this so funny, it's really-
(Felix pretending to be God for a solid 9 seconds)
Whoa, hey, hey, you can't do that. That's illegal Oh
uh oh
Uh, why are there so many of them here?
Strike them, strike them all. I'm one of you guys I'm one of you guys I swear
No head ?
All right, that was fun though. People would've been like: What?
Hey Sven!
*sss*
NOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!
OHHHHHHHHHHH
EATTTTT!! OH MY GOD,
Ohh..
*pewds in complete shock* (the caption authors too :{  )
No, I'm sorry oh
Oh
Sven, I'm sorrrrrry :(. I'm sorry, it's me. It's me. I promise look look look
It's me, PewDiePie
ooh
Oh my go- NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOo
DIE
Ohh, I wanna cry (T_T) (me too)
*sobbing*
God, Sven
Sveehehehennnnn
Ea-heheheheeheeaatt
I thought you were gonna die.. I thought you were gonna dieeee
*more sobbing* I was just trying to make a joke
*even more sobbing* oh, my god
Okay, what happened here I'll let you guys free and this is how you repay me?
I need to do fishing
Go in! they've turned my dock into a frick chamber. Stop it.
I need something to calm me down. I need something to cool my nerves a bit, good old fishing
That'll always do
What? There's a-
You can have the dragon's head. You have a human head?? how? sorry I'm learning about the game while I'm playing
It's really weird, but you can make fireworks out of the heads. So the creep red is a fire. Oh my god. That's so cool
Can you build a snowman in the nether?
No!
Does it have to be snow
Sorry, I'm sorry
What did you leave a snow trail
Okay, I just Google you can make you can make a fire assist potion and then they will survive in the nether
Obviously I have to do that. I want to build one that's just stays here
Cuz I like that he was just putting snow anywhere
Yeah, just keep keep doing y- you're doing great buddy you're doing great. Make more snow!
Okay, and then we turn it into a splash potion. I guess we'll have to be really fast
What should I name the snowmen? dumb ball?
Yes
Okay
Let's see how he fares against some enemies of the nether
Should try and make that potion land on me as well
Okay, we're gonna have to be really fast
First cut the pumpkin
Oh God okay. Well, well the snow just not melt. Wait. How do I throw the potions again? Right click, Okay
Okay, come on come on dumball
Okay, okay I gotta make the hotkeys come on dumball
We got it! It's working
He's throwing snowballs at them get him Dumball, you got this man yeah
You got nothing on us
No, dumball!
How?
Dumball. No-o
He was like father to me
He was like my own chil... Oh God, I'll take that
The trident rules all!
Yes
Rest in peace dumball. Okay, there's one final thing I want to do
So this is a regular fireworks, but then now it becomes a creeper shape. What?
Okay, so I want one blue one and one yellow one
All right gamers, follow me. I
Sven, I brought all your friends
Sven ?
Look, they're so happy
All right guys get your seats
Sven's boyfriend. There we go. Oh, that's so cute. All right guys, you ready for this?
It's a creeper face
It's so lame Wow
Thought it would be a little bigger
They love it.
They LOVE it!
Thanks for watching another episode gamers, hope you enjoyed smash
Like if you did check out the merge to support the channel: Sven, Joergen, whatever you want.
We have a ton of great options, and I really appreciate it. That's it for me for now. See you guys next time. Bye. Bye
SUBS BY SIHAM SALAMEH